tu avance rapidement il durait ce prêt
pour ça
il est mort avec 1 heure
non oui il est mort sept ans
j'en ai plus qu'assez
vous moi nous tous on est tous là crever
pour qu'ils restent de riches
tu sais qui fusille les déserteurs
l'un des fugitifs à toi ne vais pas
mourir pour que les riches puissent
vendre leurs côtes
c'est pour ça qu'on fluide mais aussi
aucun homme ne doit dire à un autre
homme pourquoi il doit vivre ni pourquoi
il doit mourir marié pas la patience de
chercher cinq ou six déserteurs caché
dans le marais des vrais
qu'on les pende
on se bat pour nos enfants et pour les
enfants de nos enfants
à partir de ce jour et déclarant que les
terres au nord du marais de pascagoula
deviendront l'état libre de kyoto
ce sont de pauvres fermiers des
déserteurs qui franchement monsieur
n'ont pas grand chose à perdre
au vent est en train de tourner
devra pas le battre cette fois
ya d'autres raisons de se battre
je devrai russe évoquée
bah
al
ighil un nom
yoyo
il
m
dieu est grand
cela il faut lui
trop risqué
déposera marché
the do à 10h12
ouais c'est certain
l'uqtr vallée d'ossau
la jeune femme